what I'm going to talk about today um
just the raft plan I'm going to give or
try to give two motivations of why um
this problem is either interesting or
why we started thinking about this
problem and then explain what the
problem is uh a combinatorial problem
about the geometry of the nend
dimensional hyper Cube and give the sort
of analytical version of it like how do
you transform this as an analysis
problem harmonic analysis problem and
give you a sketch um how to solve it
hopefully I don't know how much time we
have now due to the um schedule shift
but anyway I'll try to get through all
of that let's first start with the
motivation that uh Gil I think and a
couple of other people had mentioned in
the blog the election
interpretation um thing so let's say we
have elections like we had relatively
recently and we have two parties
Democrats and
Republicans and we have a set of Voters
they vote either Republican or
Democrat and um we want to see how the
demographic and personal characteristics
influence um the political preference of
a
person and roughly we model this as a
binary string so we have different
categories for each person uh each bid
is zero or one and represents you know
either if they're male or female if
they're married or single Urban Suburban
Etc you can add other things positions
to certain issues like pro life
pro-choice gun rights gun control etc
etc I don't know somebody's Surfer or
not Surfer I don't know you can add
whatever you want in there
so um this assuming that all possible
combinations can be found let's just now
you know make this assumption to to make
my point um the set of Voters could be
thought as um the cor the vertices of an
end dimensional hyper Cube where it's a
set of characteristics that we think
represent the political preferences of
someone uh so let's assume that we have
these four characteristics these are
voters male of married Urban and
religious male married Urban and not
religious etc
etc so what we care um is to find
typical voters what are typical voters
we call a voter typical if uh you take
their characteristics and you vary any K
of them and you expect that largely
you're going to find people that vote
for the same
party so let me make that um more and we
care to see if typical voters exist so
let me make that more precise uh let's
say that blue is what the people that
voted for uh Democrats and red are the
people that voted for Republicans um so
what we want from a typical voter X is
that if we vary any one of the
characteristics of X meaning if we take
um you know the sphere of radius one in
the cube then most of the people around
X on this sphere uh should have voted
for the same as X so for Democrats in
that specific case and we want to do
that for every sphere so for sphere
Radius 2 most of them um for X to be
typical most of them need to have voted
for the same party so for Democrat here
and Etc
so it turns out that if a party wins
with large enough Landslide then typical
vs exists exist which means uh exactly
that so if you there there there is an X
that if you vary any character any K set
of K characteristics of X then you still
find most people that vote for the same
party so and this is what we're going to
prove actually in different terms but
this is this is the point of this talk
so this is the first sort of um more I
don't know motivation that's not our
motivation but I thought it was a nice
um relation to this problem uh the
second one the second one comes from uni
games conjecture so it might seem
completely unrelated to UNI games
conjecture for those of you who know
what it is right now but that's why we
started looking at this problem and I
think it's worth mentioning because it's
interesting the path that we followed to
come to this
so is there anybody I don't think
anybody doesn't know uni games Conex
right is there anybody not not familiar
okay I mean I'll I'll talk about that
but yeah I just want to know how fast or
slow I'm going to talk about this so
Union games conjecture is a conjecture
clearly about the problem being hard and
it turns out that it's mostly useful in
studying the exact in approximability of
certain NP hard problems so as um You
probably have heard um a lot of the very
interesting computer science problems
like Max cut and vertex cover and Max
kcsp etc etc um the best approximation
algorithm known to this day matches the
uni games conjecture hardness as we call
it what does that mean it means that if
we assume that uni games is hard which I
haven't explained what uni games is but
if we assume that it is hard then it
means that the best um algorith that we
know for these problems cannot be
improved in polinomial
time so it's a very interesting tool of
explaining sort of the theory of
inapproximability and what's the status
of inapproximability of problems right
now okay so what is uni games I'm going
to go through this a bit fast because I
want to make a point um so it's a uni
games instance is a set of equations
let's say now their linear equations
modul of some prime it's as hard as in
the general case but let's focus Fus on
this case now for Simplicity so we're
given a set of linear
equations and we are asked to find the
labeling that satisfies the maximum
fraction of them okay so this is an
instance of uni games and we use K as
the alphabet size so we want to assign
values from 0 to K minus one to all of
the X SI such that most of the
constraints of the form X i- XJ equals
some C J mod K are satisfied and and the
way people and I personally like seeing
uni games is with a corresponding graph
so how do we make a graph out of an
instance we take the set of constraints
and let's assume now these are the three
simple constraints and we just put a
varable for each uh sorry a Vertex for
each variable and an edge connecting two
vertices when there was a constraint
connecting these two variables and we
you know put like the labeling or the
constraint on the The Edge so this graph
is representing this instance is that
clear so all I'm going to use yeah no
okay all I'm going to use about uni
games for to make my point is this graph
not much else uh but let me uh give you
so an example of the value of this
instance would be an assignment that
satisfies these two constraints and
doesn't satisfy that constraint or you
could use all possible three of them and
in fact this is the best you can do so
the value of this instance in this
specific case would be two 2 over three
so this is the maximum fraction of
constraints you could hope to satisfy
given this
instance
okay all right so what um uni games
conjecture say which was made by subas
um 2002 is that for every Epsilon and
Delta you give me I can find a large
enough K large enough alphabet size
such that given an instance of uni games
with alphabet SI K it is NP hard to
distinguish between the two cases where
the optimum this maximum fraction of
constraints I can satisfy is bigger than
1 minus Epsilon or the optimum is less
than Delta so what this says basically
is that if I have a 99% satisfiable
instance of uni games it is n hard to
even satisfy 1% so to come up with an
algorithm that satisfies 1% of the
constraint
all right
so and notice here that this is this is
sort of embarrassing that we don't know
what happens because if I told you that
here's a system of linear
equations tell me if it's satisfiable or
not then you would be able to tell me
really fast linear systems of equations
are easy to solve so what the uni games
conjecture say is that if I change this
satisfiability property a little bit so
if now it's not a system that's
completely satisfiable but it's almost
completely satisfiable then the problem
becomes NP hard so this is a little
strange and let me show you a really
easy algorithm that uses propagation to
solve completely satisfiable uni games
so here is a graph and let's say all of
the constraints are zero are the
identity constraint I can start with a
value and propagate across the edges and
find an assignment that satisfies
everything so this is a very simple
algorithm
uh but however this the sharp boundary
from taking this easy problem and uh
changing it a little bit makes it hard
I'm not I don't think anybody really
understands exactly why this happens uh
but let me get to um to what I really
want to say so since uni games has been
so popular the last 10 years or so maybe
11 uh a lot of people have tried both to
prove it and disprove it and the sort of
plan of attack for the class of people
that tried to disprove it was to start
ruling out cases so we looked at graphs
me and other people many other people um
and looked at this graph that before it
was a triangle this unique games
constraint graph and uh classified this
graph according to its Spectrum so the
first result of this uh sort of uh along
these lines was to say okay if this
graph that represents the instance is an
expander then uni games is no longer
hard so so we know something about a
graph that has a certain spect of
properties and now the problem all of a
sudden becomes easy meaning polinomial
time algorithm to recover an assignment
and then this um and there are a lot of
people involved in this work so I'm not
I don't know I I should mention this
Aurora and uh tulan star vishnoi Cod uh
myself ragavendra Barak a lot of um Luca
has
algorithms like a lot of people are
involved in this uni games business so
I'm not going to you know give reference
uh you know every time I talk about a
result but yeah so sorry about that um
okay so after
expanders we as a community uh went one
step further and said okay not only
expander series but now local expanders
graphs with relatively few large I
values meaning of the adjacency Matrix
large I values um so small set expanders
in some sense um are also easy so uni
games is not hard on this on this type
of
graphs and we also looked at
distributions and said okay we right now
don't know exactly what are the hard
graphs but maybe we can find a hard
distribution it turns out that random
instances average case complexity of uni
games is is p like random uh random
instances are expanders so they can be
solved in polinomial time no not only
that but also quasi random instances
which means take any graph and um just
prur randomly Epsilon fraction of the
constraints from starting from a
satisfiable instance this is also in P
so we don't really know uh any
distributions and let me say one more
thing let's go back to this spectral
profile um so graphs that are really
sparse like planer graphs and you know
trees of course planer graphs graphs
with low genus there's s sort of a
folklore you know
separator SL um ABS result aora bar and
star that shows that these graphs are
also not hard for uni games so we have
this picture now where it says that how
easy the graph is for uni games depends
on the number of large agen values of
the adjacency Matrix according to this
technology um so graphs with very few
large or bad Ain values are easy graphed
with very many large igen values are
easy easy now what remains that's the
question and in fact what remains is a
class of graphs that I mean there are
couple of graphs that we know belong to
this class but they all sort of resemble
the Boolean and includes this class of
course the Boolean hyper Cube so what as
a Next Step as you know me and Kors saw
that is to solve uni games on the hybrid
Cube this was our goal like what happens
to this graph that we know a lot about
and we had this a suggested first of all
let me again what's the hyper Cube it's
um the hyper Cube as we all know um sets
of um zer1 strings and dimension n let's
say and we use humming
distance as like the graph distance
which is the number of bits that two
vertices of the hyper Cube differ and a
sphere I'm going to use spheres a lot so
let me just Define it in the hyper Cube
around the point x of radius R are all
the points around X that differ on R
bits from X
so these are spheres according to this
humming distance on the hyper Cube uh so
let me now ask I mean that's what we
asked at the time is how about this
silly propagation algorithm show me that
it works or it doesn't work you start
from some point or maybe several points
and by some Brute Force like it's a
small set of points so you go through
all possible assignments and you pick
the best one so you start let's say from
one point for now but know probably need
to start from more uh you have some
assignment that belongs to the best
possible satisfying assignment of the
hyper Cube and here's how you propagate
this um this assignment we saw
propagation earlier now we have to do
something different for every sphere
around this point let's say we already
assigned found the best or some values
for the sphere of radius K around this
point what do we do for the sphere of
radius k + one for every point on the
sphere we look look at the neighbors of
this point in the previous sphere so
these are like okay they're not three
here but these are the neighbors and we
look at the constraints that are on the
edges remember that we've already set
those values our algorith has set those
values so what we do is we take the
majority of the votes of what these
constraints on the edges tell you and
assign this value to that point so this
is a suggested algorithm that we try to
see why it works or
doesn't Okay so let's see first of all
what do we need for this at least like
the minimum requirement for this
algorithm to work is that there exist a
point such that there is no sphere
around it that more than some little
fraction of the edges that go from SK to
SK + one are corrupted what does that
mean it means if I think of my 1 minus
Epsilon satisfiable instance of uni
games as being a completely satisfiable
instance of uni games where some
adversary picked Epsilon fraction of the
edges and made them bad like made them
unsatisfiable I want this Epsilon
fraction of bad edges to be distributed
sort of evenly so notice that this
propagation algorithm would never work
if all of the sudden in some layer
between K and K minus k + one I had all
of the edges or most of the edges that
go you know between those two spheres to
be corrupted it would be doomed to f
so the least we can you know we can like
we need to answer this question before
knowing if this algorithm works or not
is to answer this is there a point at
least one point says that no sphere
around it has a lot of errors or a lot
of corrupted edges and notice now the
trend this is kind of similar as the
voter uh thing is there a voter where no
sphere around it has majority of
Republicans if that point was Democrat
so you don't just want is there but you
want to know if most of them are like
that most of we wanted to know if there
is one we ended up proving that most of
them are but you know one would be
enough for our purposes right because
it's our starting point but how would
you know how to select it we would go
through all of them I mean
algorithmically speaking you know it's a
polinomial and the number of vertices of
the hyper Cube
so in the yeah I mean yeah fine most of
them is is better and that's what we get
so so you sure there is a point or
actually many points for which spheres
of every radius yes exact so this is
exactly the point of the talk this is
the maximum inequality that I'm going to
present these are the two motivations
which I am done with right now and I'm
going to actually talk about you know
the actual stuff but I wanted to get
these two seemingly unrelated things and
put them together and see sort of where
we CU we're not mathematici I mean we
are mathematicians I guess but we didn't
care about maximal inequalities on
anything before you know we started
working on computer science at some
point so we didn't even know these
things existed um okay
so there seem to be two differences
between the problems by uni games and
the motivated by Ving that in Ving you
counting vertices and in the uni games
you're counting edges go yeah yeah so
I'll get to that right now and in the
voting problem you have weights because
all right the voting problem is not 100%
sort of representing what we prove we
need uniform distribution of course the
stuff that but it's just like a a very
loose uh interpretation so uh again the
edges question is very good and
um we asked this question for edges
clearly and then we said okay edges
might be hard to argue what if we ask
this question for vertices so now forget
about the edges forget about the uni
games and let me describe what we
actually do so you have the hyper Cube
and again an adversary the adversary can
spoil Epsilon fraction of the very
vertices Now by making them bad so we
have a set B which are the bad vertices
of um you know cardinality Epsilon time
2 to the N Epsilon is some small
constant and we fix some threshold
Lambda that's bigger than
Epsilon let's call a sphere uh around X
of radius R bad if some Lambda or bigger
than Lambda fraction of it is bad
meaning that the adversary has put more
than Lambda fraction of the points on
the sphere be
red and we call a point x ruined if
there exists one such sphere a point can
be ruined only if one of them all of
them are perfect and one of them is bad
then the point is ruined so we're really
harsh with the point okay so is that is
that clear uh sphere is bad if a big
fraction of it is red red points point
is Ru if some sphere is
bad so now the relevant question to what
I was saying before that we ask is can
the adversary that now makes vertices
bad or red I guess and not edges can the
adversary ruin all the
vertices okay so let's see a couple of
things that the adversary could do that
we could analyze
actually um spoil a metric ball so the
adversary just starts from zero and
spoils everything of um this
radius around zero so that Epsilon
fraction of the points are spoiled uh
what happens to the rest of the points
and it turns out that only a small um
zone of boundary root n log 1/ Epsilon
is ruined and the rest of the points
majority of the cube in fact is not
ruined so it means that you know again
all the Spheres are good for these white
points so what else can the adversary do
it can ruin a subcube so these are the
only examples we could come up with um
so you know you fix some log one over
Epson coord Ates and let's say that the
adversary spoils makes red all the
vertices on this
subcube um again not much is going wrong
here because the only ruined points are
some parallel sub cubes some small
distance from the sub Cube okay
so we couldn't really uh come up with
any worse examples than this and you
know we applied the mathematician
induction as Leonard likes to say nobody
else can either therefore this must be
what's happening this must be true uh
more
precisely uh we conjectured at the time
that for all Lambda there is an Epsilon
such that for all um dimensions and for
all ruin sets of cardinality less than
Epsilon * 2 to the N sorry all the
adversary sets the red sets of
cardinality less than Epsilon * 2 to the
N the ruin set has
cardinality less than 2 to the n and I
I'll make this more precise later but
for existence purposes this is enough
and Lambda root Epsilon or some constant
root Epsilon
Works sorry where is that the Lambda is
in the definition of rooms yeah the
Lambda is in the definition all right so
we ended up proving that in a more like
concrete um set setting or definition I
guess whatever uh but first of all let
me let me just spend like a few minutes
explaining why this theorem is is
nontrivial and why why hyper Cube and
why did we have a hard time proving it
because it seems natural it seems you
know something that you know it should
probably hold however um let's let's say
the hyper Cube embeds into L1 um and we
one could assume that that's what
happens for set graphs for s that's um
graphs the thing is that if you look at
a closely related graph that's just the
Z2 grid uh mod mod n so let's say let's
take the 2D taus I guess it's called
that has 2 N plus a dimension 2 n + 1 2
n 2 n + one so around order of n Square
points um I'll show you an adversary
that can make not not a constant
fraction even smaller than constant
fraction of points red but still no
sphere here around H sorry no point is
good so let me say that a bit better
because I have I don't think I I I said
what I wanted to say so let's take this
example where we have the 2 n + 1 by 2
plus n grid and now my adversary makes
red all the diagonals with the
coordinates sum to zero mod n so the red
points now sitting on these um diagonals
and they're about order of n of them so
one Over N fraction of the total number
of points really small now I can look at
any point x take L1 balls and ask or
spheres sorry and ask is there any point
x that's not ruin well you can think
about it for a second and see that
there's always one Sphere for X that 1/4
of it is ruined so there is no hope for
this graph even if I have such a small
adversary control like the adversary
only controls one / n fraction of the
points there's no hope to find a good
starting point or a good you know all
the points are ruined so this is sort of
a
big like contrast between you know this
this type of graphs in the hyper Cube
and there is something specific about
the hyper Cube that helps us with uh I I
want ruin the suspense let me continue
um okay so the second sort of a naive
way that one could try to find or to
prove what we were trying to prove and a
second reason why this problem is
somewhat hard um is the union Bond so
one could try to approach this existance
of a point that's not ruined by using
the union bound it's a very natural it's
the first thing we we did actually um
and you know let's define by capital r
subr uh the set of points X that are
ruined by some sphere of radius R Sorry
by by the sphere of radius R exactly so
this is parameterized by the radius and
it's easy to see by Mark of inequality
that this cardinality this the number of
those points cannot be bigger than
Epsilon over Lambda uh to to the
end however if we wanted to say what
happens you know for all
radi then we would have to take a union
bound some of already ey of this bad
sets or ruined sets and we get something
useless because the dimension and comes
into play um and what I mean by that X
is ruined by sphere of radius R when
most of the points are red but it could
also be ruined by sphere of radius RP
Prime oops that most of the points are
red um and that somehow shows that this
Union bound is really over counting so
this is the problem with using the union
bound and in a particular the back to
the subcube example you know you will
see that we overcount the points a lot
of the times and by using the union
bound with this approach we just get
something that's bigger than two to the
end whereas we just showed that we have
so so little points that are so few
points that are
ruined and in fact this always happens
it turns
out okay so these are the main
two sort of points that I wanted to get
across before I move to the actual
result and if you have any questions now
it's a good time to ask
probably so you can ask this question on
any
graph you could yes and it's not true
for the is it true for
expand yeah I think we've talked about
this question before too right you and I
or I don't know
possibly I I remember I mean I I've
talked to
someone I I'm not entirely sure I mean
you have to have
a yeah I I don't know we don't know the
answer to this question I mean we I
guess Leonard is is here yes you're
working on this product graphs right and
yeah well first of all to say one thing
about expanders is I I doubt it it's
characterized in quite that way because
it's really very sensitive to uh plus
minus a little bit in the distances like
you know sphere is a really sharply
defined object and expanders have a
little more play in them so I'm not
quite sure that's likely to be the way
these things behave um we do have a
conjecture which we put in the paper
that this you'll say at the end I want I
I wasn't that this would hold for uh
cartisian products of any bounded size
graph it seems very hard
but yeah I mean we we don't really know
I mean we know a lot of things about
maximal inequalities in general which
I'll mention um in in a little bit but
not for such like discrete sort of I
don't know graphs I
guess okay another question um the
relationship between the adversary
spoiling edges and vertices so you said
yeah this is a bit you know it's not
exact yeah I just wanted to say that we
asked this Edge question and then we
asked the vertex question and we solved
the vertex question there is an edge
version which is not exactly I mean it's
harder to argue about edges so it's open
the corresponding question for
edges the thing is what would the
corresponding question for edges um
or if you didn't come back to that yeah
yeah let's come back to because there is
something but it's not you know exactly
what this gives
you um okay so I I just want to take
what I just said and put it in analysis
terms so I'm not going to do much
different in the next couple of slides
just give you the sort of math version
of it so we're looking always at L2 Norm
so I'm going to omit the two from the
norm but it's always L2 and functions in
L2 um so we look at the set of functions
which are really real valued functions
on the hyper Cube take the norm which is
the standard L2 norm and represent the
fun um sort of H set B which would be
the red points for us with the indicator
function one when it's red zero
otherwise and the cardinality of B is
equal to the uh square of this function
this is a 01 function so you know it
doesn't really matter if you take
squares or not uh but anyway so B is are
the adversary set the set that the
adversary made red and L2 squ Norm of
this indicator function is equal to the
cardinality of B uh so now we look at um
we want to look at operators but let's
first see uh what we get from markups
inequality we get that the cardinality
of points that a function is greater
than Lambda is less than uh the norm of
a function squared over Lambda squar
simple application of micros inequality
and moreover let's consider any oper
if we know that this operator has
bounded Norm 2 to2 Norm then we can get
a similar statement that the cardinality
of X such that this operator applied on
f of x is bigger than Lambda is less
than this Norm squared this constant
whatever this a is you know Norm of f^2
over Lambda squ so for our application
what we care is about sphere operators
what are those those objects are just a
average of my function over the points
of some sphere so Sr f of x is the sum
of the function f on the points on the
sphere radius are around X over a
cardinality of the sphere just the the
average uh in order to argue about the
sort of ruined set how many vertices
have some sphere that is uh sort of has
a lot of bad points we need to introduce
the maximal operator
what is the maximal operator well apply
to F you just look at all the radi so
maximal operator of this family of
operas f of x you just take the maximum
over all
radi of the this average on the sphere
so what you really do I think I have a
picture here um let me first show you
the picture assume now we only had two
spheres which is not the case um so
let's say this is X this is one sphere
around X and the average red is where
the function is one and green is where
the function is zero so the average of
the value of the function on the first
sphere would be 6 the average of the
value of the function of the second
sphere would be 64 so if you take the
maximum of those two is 64 so the maxim
Operator just looks at every possible
radi and takes the maximum average of
the value of the function on the sphere
so now what our problem means uh if we
wanted to find the cardinality of the
ruin set this Union of Ruin sets at
radius of Ruin points at radius R this
is just the points X such that the
maximal operator f ofx is bigger than
Lambda because that would mean there
exist a sphere there might be many
doesn't matter um that this average of
the points of the value of the function
of the points of the sphere is bigger
than Lambda
how um okay
and all right so
the theorem that we ended up showing is
that this maximal function has bounded
operator Norm independent of the
dimension which means that L to Norm of
Ms of f is less than some a which is
constant uh Norm of f for all F bounded
etc etc uh and by this what do we get we
get that the cardinality of the ruin set
by this Mark of inequality that I just
mentioned a couple of slides ago is less
than uh this quantity and you know by
picking some Lambda of the order root
Epsilon we get that the ruin set is very
small in fact which comes back to the
existence versus majority question so
this is this is the maximum
inquality um thing that we
show and um in fact let me cuz maximum
inquality is not something we came up
with clearly uh it's something that
exists Ed since 20s or maybe even
earlier in sort of more continuous
spaces and a lot of people have done
tremendous amount of work on maximal
inequalities u in fact it starts I think
with Hardy and littlewood uh who studied
um a similar problem but now it's ukian
space of nend dimensions and they
studied the ball operators instead of
spheres which you take everything around
the point that's at distance at at most
R and they considered the these
averages of value of functions on boths
around the point and managed to show
that this maximal operator which is
defined exactly the same just take the
supremum of all the balls around the
point um of the average of the function
is in fact bounded but now they bound
was depending on the dimension and
notice that this is okay cuz now we're
looking at infinite infinite um things
like a lot of balls a lot of points it's
nothing to do with a hyp I mean a bound
on the dimension would be trivial for
our case is just the union bound that we
got before so most of the flavor of
maximal inequalities in ukian spaces or
other spaces had something to do with a
dimension often there were some discrete
results but not which I'll talk about uh
in a bit so anyway this is sort of the U
regime where maximal inequalities were
mostly studied in analysis and in notice
that we can't use this if we wanted to
use some black box sort of knowledge
it's a wrong magicc space we have balls
and um there's not Dimension
independent and again as let me stress
this out again uh it would be enough if
we had the result for spherical means in
L1 but this is what we can get as the
example of the
Z2 this grid with a diagonal showed so
this is also something we can use and
something is special about the hyper
Cube to be honest I'm not entirely sure
what that is it has to do with Spectrum
but um yeah I can really yeah say and
these are a lot of people that worked on
maximum inequalities and
contributed uh to that okay since I have
a lot of time let me say a little bit
about the proof um so our the way we to
show this and again let me pull this
slide up in case you
forgot say that again sorry
yes I didn't hear Maxim inequalities do
not depend on the dimension the hyper
Cub ones yes cuz I mean if they did then
we would have done not much uh but yeah
ours is just constant bound on the
operator yeah okay so this is what I'm
sketching how we show with a some
constant Dimension
independent so our proof has two main
steps and at each step we had the set of
operators we took the maximal function
you know respect to the set of operators
and we compared it to another maximal
function on a different set of operators
that was more tractable so this is sort
of the both of the steps you know
compare something to something and this
something to something else which we
know bounds
about so the step one remember we had
this uh s subk which were the average of
the sphere of radius K of the value of
the function of the sphere and we
defined this objects called Senate
operators so Senate of this uh family of
operators of R is just the uniform
average of all the operators in my
family from zero to R what does that
mean Senate of the sphere operators of
radius 5 would be one over six of all
the sums of the sphere operators from
radius 0 to five and why do we call the
Senate well it's I think Leonard came up
with this I'm not entirely sure um it's
because of the US Senate thing like how
the US Senate gets voted it's equal
contribution from
everyone population what's
that California right so we regardless
of the population so yeah we could have
called this something else but I like
this yeah it's very politics a lot of
politics in this talk
okay yeah it's not a h well we're trying
to bound hunas with senates right so we
try to prove that democracy is better in
some sense uh mean that's what we do
like because s are just you know the one
sphere so anyway we Define this Senate
operators which are uniform averages
over uh our family of operators and we
can take maximal function funs of this
operators or any set of operators which
is just again look at already i r and
take the maximum of a senate of R of f
ofx uh so in the first part we use uh a
method developed originally by St Ste uh
to bound this uh operator for the sphere
maximal inequality with um some constant
times the operator for the Senate of
spheres plus some error term and most of
the work uh here is to bound this error
term I I'll tell say more about that
which is it yeah I think it was Terry
th's
advisor yeah uh it's really hard to read
his paper that's that's the moral of the
story from this it's incredibly hard to
read these papers um
okay so yeah this was like about a twool
line proof that took us maybe two months
to figure out what he was trying to say
okay so the Second Step remember now we
have we need to bound this term
now the Second Step uh introduces
something that we saw at the boot camp
uh about uh this talks on the hyper Cube
that Kristoff gave and it's just this
noise operators parameterized by t uh
where
basically you run an independent pon
blocked uh processes and um with
parameter one from time 0 to T and you
flip H bit if you have odd uh events in
the you you flip bit ey if you had odd
events in the if Plus on process um so
this is sort of like a Quon clocked
random walk on the hyper Cube every you
should know everything about that by now
I guess by uh this lectures so at the
second uh the Second Step what we do is
we manage to bound the maximum operator
for senates with the maximum operator
for Senate for sorry for Senate of
spheres with the maximum operator for
sentence of this um n which um we call
it noise
operator and uh after that our life is
easy now because these things were known
and we know that the operator of this
type of um noise operators um or any
semi- group in fact is bounded by uh in
fact
every P Norm is bounded but for two Norm
we get two
root2 okay
so yes I think I have it explicitly
later but yes um okay so big picture you
want to bound the uh maximum operator of
spheres you bound this maximum operator
of senet plus some error term that turns
out to be some constant times F and you
bound that by sen of noise operators
plus f meaning um in total you get about
constant times
F okay so let me talk a little bit more
about each step in particular um so the
first step um we we are required like
the the most of the work becomes it
comes to bounding this error term which
uses some cist wordss the main step is
CIS wordss pretty much uh but anyway
some some consist wordss that alstein
had used in his proof and
some interesting thing that we didn't
know before some spectral bounds on the
family of the sphere operators and as an
intuition which does not entirely sort
of apply directly I mean we would like
it to apply directly but that's why this
whole process works is that um the
sphere operator of radius K somehow
resembles the noise operator of K Over N
uh because you know we have this n to be
the average of SK for this r range of
parameters and you know direct
comparison is very difficult that's why
we go through this um indirect way uh
but it turns out that we were able to
show that the Spectra of these two
operators are somewhat similar and here
is what it means if you look at NT um
the igen vectors are characters with
igen value 1 / 2T X for character of a
size X um and SK was known is known uh
to have I values um called kic
polinomial and this kic polinomial again
for character y of length x we denoted
cruk of K of X um so what we sort of
managed to show is that the behavior of
this aen Val was similar to 1 - 2 k/n X
which would give what we want in fact
that's our main LMA in this step one of
the proof that cic pols are bounded uh
by
this was
that not that I know of I mean we we
worked hard for those I don't know if
it's already known then I don't know I
should have known that but yeah um
anyway so that's sort of the sort of the
the step one was it came down to this
CIS and this bounce on the Aon values of
the sphere operators and step two is
sort of a more direct pointwise
comparison of the Senate the sphere
opers with the Senate uh of these noise
operators so let me mention a little bit
um why these noise operators are easy to
handle and it's because erotic maximal
inequalities already existed and were
well known um that means if you have a
double stochastic Matrix T and you
consider the semi- group T2
VR any semi group um you can prove a
bounded by constant um maximal
inequality for this Senate of semi-
groups and you sort of n as Kristoff
mentioned previous week forms a semi-
group we use known Machinery we can get
that the norm of the Senate of n uh is
bounded uh the intuition behind this
this second step is that while you know
a prior if you look at it n is indeed
very different from a single uh sphere
operator uh it's just an aage over um
spheres almost however the sence of the
two things are not that different so if
you look at the coefficients of how many
times SK appears in one and the other
they're sort of the same within constant
they're sort of the same and you know
I'm browsing a lot of things here
because there is some technical things
you need to do but eventually uh by
stochastic domination of this Set uh by
the the other we're able to show the
norm
comparison okay I think that's it and I
still I'm looking still for applications
of this in computer science or somewhere
so if someone knows about any
applications combinatorics is okay
combinatorics is okay medicine is okay
biology is okay I don't know yeah H then
I still want to see what happens uni
games on the hyper Cube
I'm still working on that and yeah I
guess I would mention the other graphs
where maximum inequality holds these
product graphs um etc
etc
okay one thing to mention which I guess
we had before but so you proved you know
a key maximum inequality this L2 to L2
but of course in the classical Theory
there's a whole Leora of other ones in
particular assuming say just an L1 bound
can you get a weak one one yes which we
don't know that would be maybe the most
natural missing piece
but
but I guess the other thing is that as
you emphasized in this low dimensional
example L1 doesn't work but in low
Dimensions it does work if the Spheres
have curvature as if you work in LP for
p different from one right so somehow
philosophically one can say that what
you show is that in you know in the
hyper Cube even the L1 spheres have
curvature and there is actually a theory
of curvature in discrete spaces that
didn't um you know for related to mixing
of Mark of chain and so on has been um
and and you know it would be interesting
to so
there I've never heard about that but we
you should let me know what yeah to Olia
right a curvature is one n right that's
right so so this so
this some curvature is known to be the
key in infinite dimensional spaces so
maybe there is a relation between these
kind of two extensions this is nice of
CV yeah this is really
nice more questions maybe I can give an
answer if not a question just another
little thing well first of all regard to
the last comment so there's Ben Krauss
was his name so oh yeah I believe
there's an LP version now but not for
not a week one one but I believe there's
an LP for p strictly greater than one
version of our theorem recently Ben
Krauss I think and and I just wanted to
answer response to the edge questions
before so actually if you want to know
that every every sphere around the point
where by sphere you mean all the edges
of a certain distance from a point then
you can easily get it from this so if
that was what you meant by The Edge
question
so basically you take you have Epsilon
bad edges duplicate their weight at each
of their neighboring vertices so you
doubled Epsilon and now you get it from
the vertex I think he meant if you have
a function on the edges or which now if
you want a function on the if you want a
version for the line graph I think well
okay that's another I was asking because
of I was trying to understand the
implication from your result well right
now there is no implication because this
algorithm fails for other
reasons so
there's no hope I mean there is hope but
not with this
approach yeah so yeah there's no the
purpose of reality is to inspire good
theories so in this case yeah
exactly so more questions okay so let
speak